and it's just about to explode into
other dimensions I was shown my legacy
the end of the path I started us on and
just to see all of them coming together
it's a daring act the hell are you guys
with infinity war we're paying off every
little thread and every little tease
that we've had in what will be 18 films
prior to infinity war there's never been
anything like this
being able to film after film teased at
a larger story really building these
stories up into a giant conclusion while
at the same time introducing an entirely
new direction for the future
[Music]
new direction for the future is right so
hey everybody is Charlie Marvel just
announced six untitled movies for phase
four with dates so I wanted to do a
video explaining because there are 10
now 10 Marvel movies starting with
Spider Man 2 which picks up in the wake
of Avengers 4 spider-man 2 is the
beginning of Marvel phase 4 so I'll say
there's a new round of that Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so a lot of you
probably have a pretty good idea for at
least half of these movies some of them
are a foregone conclusion there's gonna
be an Avengers sequel there's gonna be a
Black Panther sequel there'll be another
spider-man film there'll be a Black
Widow film so some of these are pretty
easy to guess and some of them already
have release dates but remember there's
10 total
so starting spider-man 2 july 2019
there's only gonna be one phase 4 movie
during that year because they have
Captain Marvel and Avengers 4 so Marvel
is gonna stick to it's 3 movies per year
schedule that seems like it's gonna be
their thing for the rest of time so in
like ten years when we're on Marvel
phase 7 they'll still be doing three
movies per year not including any
potential x-men movies or Deadpool
universe movies that they might do when
they get that IP so right now we're just
talking about classic MCU films I'll
figure in the Fantastic Four Galactus
x-men of it all as we get closer and
closer to that 2022 date because right
now that seems like it's gonna be the
end of the next phase of movies so when
you're talking to your friends the
easiest way to explain different eras of
Marvel films is in those Avengers films
whatever the action of those are so
until they give us an official title and
let us know about what some of those
other bigger Avengers films are gonna be
after Avengers 4 just think of phase 4
as the New Avengers era because they're
cycling characters out there cycling new
characters in the title rights itself
Avengers 5 the New Avengers coming May
20-22 when it comes to that next
Avengers film because we're doing two
back-to-back I think that might wait up
to three years depending on how well
their box office does that's why there's
always gonna be a film with Avengers in
the title every couple of years they
really interesting ones or when they try
weird stuff like if they ever do an a
force movie but then we have guardians 3
that's already got a date for mate
20 I think I shall call him it's gonna
be the Last Guardian to film with this
roster and all I think that means is is
they'll continue to do Guardians films
it'll just be different characters and
James Gunn isn't gonna direct every
single one of them like eventually he'll
just move on to more of an executive
producer role and do other films in the
Marvel Universe easy money says there's
gonna be a black panther - there's gonna
be a Captain Marvel - there'll be a
third Spider Man film sometime later in
that roster because they have one in
2019 so within two years of spider-man -
a Doctor Strange film a black widow
movie we don't have any release date for
that yet they're still working on the
script so it's probably gonna be at
least three years before we see that
that still leaves a couple movies on the
schedule like is there gonna be another
Iron Man solo film is there gonna be
another Thor solo film they've expressed
interest in doing stuff like that but
mostly it's just them waiting for the
right script to come along so I think a
lot of those later untitled movie
release dates are in case they find that
good story but they always have four or
five different movie ideas so in case
one idea that they're really looking for
it doesn't come on schedule they have
another movie that's ready to go they
can slot in there but James Gunn has
also been very open about him and Kevin
Feige developing the Marvel cosmic
universe meaning that we'll get non
guardians space based Marvel movies so
new characters we've never seen before
for those of you asking for an OVA film
we could always get an OVA film there
period films set in outer space
so like Captain Marvel is a movie set
during the 90s that's the closest we've
had to a period film besides Captain
America whatever those non guardians
films are they're just gonna be super
weird and they're gonna try stuff out so
if they're not super successful it's not
the end of the world they already have a
lot of proven franchises that they can
just roll out if they need to start
printing their own money which is
basically what Marvel's doing at this
point it's like a cash machine just
spitting out money to anybody that wants
to make movies
I've already talked a little bit about
future spider-man sequels about how they
could cross him over with other
characters the future of Marvel movies
even though a lot of these will have
solo titles like it'll be Black Panther
2 or Captain Marvel 2 they will be
crossover films featuring other Avengers
characters so I mean obviously the title
has to be whatever the title is gonna be
but pretty much all of the movies since
civil war have been team-up movies so
you could call them low-level Avengers
films it's just they don't have Avengers
in the title so I do think it's totally
possible that they could try an A Force
movie because like Tessa Thompson and
some of the other bigger female
characters have talked about doing a
film together like you know what would
that be it would basically be a force
which is an all-female Avengers team led
by she-hulk who isn't a character in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but hasn't
ever been a big problem for Marvel like
if there's a character that's missing
like the Mandarin from the Iron Man
mythos they just do something else in
its place so if they want to do an a
force film they have plenty of
characters to put in that but here's
where we get to the Fantastic Four the
x-men the Galactus of it all what
happens if the merger goes through
without a hitch if there's not any big
problems Kevin Feige said that they
really only have most of their films
locked in to 2020 so like I said this
release date goes up to 2022 some of
those untitled films later than the
schedule could change to become x-men
crossover movies or they're just Marvel
movies with x-men characters in them so
like you could actually potentially see
the Fantastic Four show up during
Avengers 5 and they could still call the
movie new Avengers it's just that you
have Reed Richards running around with
all the other Avengers characters in
there so technically it is a big x-men
crossover but for those of you asking
about like full-blown Secret Wars or
x-men vs. Avengers stuff like that
honestly I don't think that any of
that's gonna happen till like phase 5 so
we're talking like 2023 to 2025 like 7
to 10 years down the road I think what
you'll see Marvel do once they do get
control of those characters they still
at Fox make their x-men their Deadpool
films do their own things so like
Deadpool is his own little universe he
exists by himself he has his x-force
characters they have their big running
narrative you do a couple sequels
no worries if that's working and it's
doing really well people love it there's
no reason to change that that's just
lazy writing if the mainstream x-men
franchise can get it together same
deal for that too if it doesn't what you
might see happen is is they still keep
x-men in its own little self-contained
universe but they reboot the property
with new actors and it becomes a full
Marvel production in the way that
spider-man is a full Marvel production
so Sony is a really good template for
what they might do with Fox
so like Fox will still be its own
separate company they still own those
characters it's just the Disney will
have access to cherry-pick if they want
to bring some characters from that into
the other Marvel movies it's not as
complicated as it sounds I know people
are just wondering like when are we
gonna see Galactus in the Fantastic Four
fight with the Avengers in the same film
when are we gonna see Wolverine join the
Avengers stuff like that is probably 7
to 10 years away like they're gonna give
Hugh Jackman some distance from the
Wolverine character I'm not expecting
any kind of Wolverine reboot the only
Wolverine character you'll probably see
running around in the Marvel Universe is
Deadpool when he's making fun of Hugh
Jackman and then the Laura character so
for the most part business as usual on
the Marvel in the Fox side of things but
five to seven years down the road you'll
see that slowly blending together and
honestly I think the Fantastic Four will
probably be the point of crossover
because Reed Richards the multiverse
Doctor Strange we're starting to do that
in the MCU right now so that is the key
to introducing the Fantastic Four in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe just an
alternate reality that's where all the
x-men characters live just adjacent to
our MCU reality but if you have any
questions just let me know in the
comments below for the most part they're
gonna wait to announce every single one
of those films for a while you'll find
out about the next couple of ones pretty
soon like Black Panther - they haven't
formally announced that that'll be one
of the next things they do because we're
in the Marvel corridor now we have
Deadpool coming up we have Avengers
infinity war there's gonna be a bunch of
Marvel videos leave all your requests in
the comments below and let me know what
films do you want them to do during
phase 4 that they haven't announced yet
the giveaway will just keep going on in
all my Marvel videos so I'll announce a
winner the next time I post this weekend
click here for like that full
phase four promo that they just dropped
leading up to infinity war and click
here for brand new Deadpool thank you so
much for watching everybody's there
awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]